الثلج المتساقط في فصل الشتاء هدف العلماء
القادم لانتاج طاقه كهربائيه نظيفه
ومتجدده وذاتي تكلفه منخفضه فبعد تصميم
العلماء للطرق مبتكره لاستعاب طاقه معظم
القوى الطبيعيه الاساسيه كالماء ورياح
والشمس جاء الدور على الثلوج العلماء في
مدينه امور اليابانيه والتي تشهد ثلوج
كثيفه سنويا يعملون على تطوير تقنيه جديده
لتوليد الطاقه الكهربائيه من الثلوج
التجارب تقوم على تبادل الحراري بين الثلج
والهواء المحيط واستغلال الفرق درجه
الحراره لتوليد كهرباء نظيفه من خلال
التعاون بين باحثين في جامعه طوكيو وشركه
محليه الناشئه وياتي المشروع الياباني
لمواجهه ازمه نقص الطاقه من جهه وارتفاع
تكاليف ازاله الثلوج من جهه اخرى اذ تتعرض
اليابان لازمه طاقه تفاقمت في يونيو
الماضي جراء تداعياته الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]